you are a Cuban Heritage yes and I have
to say it's I I don't know if this is
part of your heritage but you're so
Suave you have kind of an elegant
demeanor that I could never have I just
think it's not in my blood you know what
I mean is that possible uh that's
possible yeah thank you but I also like
you're a bit of a throwback I mean you I
whenever I see photos of you and photo
shoots you're very elegantly dressed you
know you believe in dressing up that's
important to you well you know what it's
part of my culture it's really a
throwback to my family my father and my
uncle they were they uh it's a way of
kind of keeping their memory alive for
me they're both that's cool that's the
way it is yeah do you have like for
example uh your son does he dress up in
the same way do you have rules for him
do you want him to to sort of carry on
the tradition well you know we got to
start with and you can't show the crack
of your ass that's
[Applause]
he's young it's a different time we're
working so you're deciding which silk
tie to wear and you and and for him it's
just like hide that crack of the ass
yeah he doesn't go there anymore I
noticed that he's you know he's he you
know he's buttoned up he's fine you know
I think it's a thing I believe there's
an age I know what happened with me
where I never cared about clothes when I
was younger right I got a little older
and I remember starting to notice like
hey I feel better when I dress up no and
don't you feel that you that there is
some example that was laid before you by
your your parents or someone that you
know your grandfather or somebody that
you might sort of subconsciously emulate
they were slobs
it's not the same tradition no I always
felt like sometimes there is something
too like when I became a dad I noticed I
started wearing a jacket more or like
trying to dress up a little bit because
I got a little self-conscious like I'm a
dad you have to set an example yeah yeah
I just can't walk around you know yeah
cracking my ass with my New Kids on the
Block t-shirt it's a sad Look Into My
Life
um
I was watching in in Rio 2 you display I
know that you're very Musical and you
get to show a little that in Rio too
with your character you know you're it's
a very musical film you know so Joe
Mendes uh worked on a lot of the music
and carlina's brown and it's a bunch of
Brazilian artists in uh in the film it's
really uh it's a beautiful film really
is for the the kids are really going to
enjoy it they like the first one but
this movie is really terrific you get to
do some beatboxing in it you know a
little bit I'm not sure what that is
you use your vote you sort of vocal
percussion you use vocal percussion oh
yeah is that what they call it nowadays
yeah nowadays
yes there's this new group Run DMC you
have to check out
what do you call I gotta show the crack
of my ass
well beatboxing you know what they call
it I don't know what I don't know what
they call it now it's been going on for
centuries right I mean you know you guys
look at the band right they don't yeah
no
they're going like this
they do that before the show and after
the show
they just sleep during the show
um no I'm I'm like you know the
now don't laugh at that that's very good
that's
that's that is
some people were laughing as if that
weren't excellent
but yeah it's that kind of thing you see
the spit on my face
we need to towel you off now sorry about
that that's okay I actually did that
very well you know I could see well half
of that was me choking
hahaha